when Javier Bardem and I were working on
before night falls and we did the scene
where he walks into this to this prison
and he's supposed to be stoned on LSD
there was 150 prisoners behind this this
huge cells and they were screaming their
heads off and we did this thing in a
basically one take the feeling that he
had after doing that and the feeling
that I had gave us enough energy to sort
of go on and work in a daunting schedule
where you're working 16 or 18 hour days
where certain things might not be
working whether it's in your private
life or with other responsibilities but
for a moment there just for that moment
the clarity and the success of executing
that gave you enough sense of yourself
and a sense of accomplishment to
actually try to achieve that moment
again that maybe we could actually have
a complete film at the end of that
process or if everything was going wrong
and I could go into the studio and
somehow I don't have to know if it's
good or bad I don't I don't even have to
know what it is I could go in there and
nobody has to understand what I'm
thinking I have to convey anything to
anybody else I could just do that and
then come back and look at it and kind
of see where I was and what that was
because I posited that impulse the
horror or whatever that was into that
thing and transmuted it into something
else so I would say that if you say oh
I'm depressed I can't do this I can't
work if you don't work if you don't
paint you can't be a painter if you
don't write you can't be a writer if you
don't film something you're not a
filmmaker so all those people that are
sitting around thinking oh god I might
make a bad film or I might make a bad
painting or maybe somebody won't like
this
you're doomed if that's going to deter
you from that we all have insecurities
and doubts but I think that it's better
to make a mistake than not to do
anything if you win you win and if you
lose you win